we will begin again and remake humanity
without the corruption
greed and hatred that the inner planets
could not transcend
fred grunted and shook his head i don't
see it inaros is charismatic and he's
smart watching his press release
he certainly thinks he's in charge but
he'd have to the man's a first-rate
narcissist and a sadist besides
he'd never knowingly share power with
anyone if he could help it the level of
organization
of coordination it seems beyond his
reach fred gestured toward the screen
the light from it glowed in his eyes
tiny images of inaros giving his salute
it doesn't feel right he's the kind of
man who carries a lot of weight in a
small circle
playing at this scale isn't what he does
best he isn't a bad tactician
and the timing of the attacks was showy
in a way that seems like he was likely
behind them and he's charming at the
negotiation table but he's not a
first-class mind
and this is a first-class operation i
don't know how to put it better than
that
hey guys pete here those are words that
the show's version of fred johnson will
never speak to holden
i'm still a little rocked from the last
episode but it's time to move on
today i'm going to do a preview video of
the expanse season 5
episode 5 which is titled down and out
i'm going to look at where all the
characters were
at the end of episode 4 and take a
closer look at some of the details that
we're probably supposed to be paying
attention to
quick spoiler warning there will be tons
of spoilers in this
if you aren't caught up with the expanse
through season 5 episode 4.
i'm gonna refer to the books but i won't
give away any future spoilers from them
that's your warning and if you feel like
you gotta go please hit the subscribe
button on your way out
now let's jump in alex and bobby served
as our window
into the martian perspective in the last
episode
they're in pursuit of admiral soviter
and emily babbage in the ship the bar
keith
beyond them being generally shady and
emily asking
alex a lot of questions about the
proto-molecule and what happened when
they arrived on illus we don't know much
of what's going on with them
we do know they're traveling in three
ships and the only thing on their
heading
is a squadron from the third fleet alex
doesn't want to believe that there could
be a conspiracy this
big and bobby points out that yes three
ships means that three crews either have
to be in on it or they're being paid to
look the other way
she's convinced that they're gonna stop
and meet up with the black marketeer
and of course we never find out in
episode 4 because they get the alert
about the asteroid
and a nearly simultaneous attack on the
martian parliament building
as far as book 5 is concerned this is
all slightly different so it's not 100
clear what's going on here so to go off
of just what we've seen on screen so far
we know through ashford's story last
season that there's likely some kind of
connection
with some martian military and the free
navy at the same time bobby has
uncovered
a lot of people making money selling
weapons to them
so we can't say for sure how big the
conspiracy is
the martian side of things is the least
developed as far as what we saw go
down so i'm very interested to see where
they take this
on earth amos and clarissa who i'm going
to refer to as peaches from now on
are underground in the pit they're near
where the second rock dropped and we saw
that even
way underground they saw some effects
from the impact
as the ceiling had a giant crack so we
can expect damage on a scale from total
chaos on the low end to complete
destruction on the surface above them
on the other end there's a lot of
questions about how bad these asteroid
impacts were
how much damage they're gonna do based
on what we've seen we don't really know
the answers to that yet i imagine that
we're gonna learn a lot about that
firsthand
through peaches and amos's perspective
because it is safe to say that they are
going to have to try to escape the
prison
and that things are going to be
drastically different on the surface
when they get there
a question you might have had about this
matchup is
why is he going to see her after all she
tried to kill holden
she put a bomb on the sung yoon and then
she sent out the fake message from
holden
which went a long way to get things
started around the slow zone
and a lot of people died and after that
remember amos was all about just killing
her right there
anna and naomi convince him not to and
then she does actually help save the day
when she deactivates the behemoth calm
laser and that's somewhat redeeming but
it doesn't undo what she did
or explain why amos is interested in
seeing her
when he goes to earth in my episode 4
breakdown i said that it looked like he
was figuring out that he wanted to help
clarissa in real time
like she asked him the question and he
isn't sure about the answer until he
thinks about it
it's like he's compelled to go see her
but he doesn't know why and we can't
imagine that a lot happened
off screen when they were coming back
from the slow zone over the couple of
months that she was a prisoner on the
rossi but in the books at least we never
really learn any more about that
so that idea that he doesn't know why
wes chatham actually confirmed this
in the after show that they do on the
amazon channel
and it emphasizes why these two work
together even though they don't
necessarily make sense
as mentioned he said he was compelled to
go there he didn't really know why
and he figured it out while they were
there that he wanted to help her
because even though they come from very
different backgrounds about as different
as you can imagine
he wanted to give peaches that same
thing that lydia gave him
and one of the things that's really
missing from a book reader's perspective
here
is that we don't hear amos's internal
dialogue and while that doesn't really
explain any of this
it does help to explain how he got there
without having a solid plan of what he
wanted to do
or really an understanding of what he
might be able to offer her
as fate would have it the rock drops and
the situation
changes immediately we saw him struggle
through this personal interaction
because he doesn't really know how to
act like that he doesn't really know how
to
interact with people in that way now
they're in a purely survival situation
they're stuck underground with all these
really bad people
that all have body modifications that
make them superhuman more or less
and the world outside is falling apart
and i don't know about you but if i was
in peach's situation
i don't think there's a better person
you could hope to be with than amos
especially when he's on your side
elsewhere
nancy gao's decision to stay on the
planet that brought about her demise
and that means that the un has no leader
at the moment later in the episode we
learned that with all the chaos that's
going on the line of succession is
unclear
i think it's a good guess that abba
sarala will have some part to play
in that obviously she uncovered the plot
she knew what was going on
fortunately she was on luna so she's
safe and in her last sequence we saw
that they were able to re-test the
watchtower satellites
and that should help to protect earth
from any future asteroids
a big question mark in abu sarah's story
is also her husband and her family
she's not able to reach them she doesn't
know what's going on
and we'll have to wait and see how bad
things are on earth before we know
how much danger they're in on tycho we
did see fred johnson's death
i'm kind of bummed about it i was really
enjoying him withholding this season
and he was shot in the books when they
stole the proto-molecule but he survived
and there were some aspects of his story
that come after that i will miss
but i kind of feel like they wouldn't
have changed this if they didn't have a
good story reason to do it what do we
miss with fred being gone well like that
quote that i opened the video with he is
able to give holden insight into who
marco is
he doesn't know him well but he does
know of him and he certainly could slip
in a different belter to do that part
or even use monica because you know she
seems to have been
talking to people inside his
organization what's really missing when
you lose fred is he was the opposite
side of the coin
from marco with the ring gates being
open life in the belt is going to change
we'll talk about marco in a second but
his idea is that he wants to take
control of the belt with force
while fred was trying to make alliances
build his own navy but ultimately work
with the inners
instead of fighting against them but he
is gone and there's nothing changing
that
and his sample is also
no longer secure all of that adds up to
it not being very hard to figure out
where holden's mind's going
he has the healthiest of all fears of
the proto-molecule
and certainly won't want to see that end
up in the wrong hands
but his life partner is also with marco
anarro
it's curious that they wanted monica for
some reason
this could be as simple as they just
wanted her for what she does
she's a reporter a journalist so they
could have used her
as a mouthpiece but i imagine that we
can expect that she'll stick next to
holden
at least for the foreseeable future and
as i said it's not a stretch to think
that he's going to want to go after
the proto-molecule and go looking for
naomi and they do have sakai as a
prisoner
who was working closely with the free
navy and she may turn out to be
an asset we also have kamina drummer she
wasn't in the episode so there isn't
much that we can say
she was planning on hunting marco she
said that she wanted to collect the
bounty
it would help provide for her family
give them some security
plus she hates him because he killed
ashford now he's killed fred johnson
so it'll be interesting to see how she
reacts what her crew thinks about the
new situation
if you go back and watch the season 5
trailer there's quite a few shots of her
with the free navy her family's there
it's not clear what's going on and i
can't wait to find out what her plan is
if that is a plan or what's going on
there
marco inaros and the free navy is the
last thing we need to talk about
what's he want what's he doing he just
committed
a massive atrocity he said it was in
retaliation
for generations of atrocities that the
inners have committed against the belt
he's not necessarily wrong about that
and those real grievances
are shared by a percentage of the
population but these methods will be far
too
extreme for a lot of belters they may
not like earth they may not like earth's
government
and the things that the inner planets
and their corporations have done
but they wouldn't accept this level of
incredible violence
so what does he want he wants power
obviously you don't need to know that
much more about him
if you just pay close attention to his
scenes on the pella
the way he interacts with naomi and with
his son you could see that he's a
manipulator
in the excerpt i read fred describes him
as a narcissist
and that seems fair and he saw an
opportunity in all the uncertainty
that's hanging over the belt
to commit this act of terrorism and try
to consolidate power
and in his twisted logic he'll have this
navy they'll regulate all the
colonization going through the ring
gates to the new planets
and in that they can preserve this way
of life for people who live in the belt
who are going to lose whenever their
resource extraction is no longer
important and they can't go
and live on these new worlds either so
there's some demagoguery going on
if he can take control he doesn't really
have to win popular support from
all of the belters he can appeal to
their desires he can appeal to their
fears
and if the free navy can control the
ring gates take power away from the
inner planets
by taking away their ability to control
that then everyone would have to go
through him
and if he pulls it off it is an
impressive feat since no one would ever
be able to have done something like that
in the past one thing that he seems to
have that no
other belter's ever had is access to
martian technology
due to the political situation on mars
he was able to get a hold of the stealth
composites
that made the rocks possible and he's
also flying around in a pretty
impressive martian warship if you go to
the x-ray feature on amazon prime you
can see some illustrations of the pella
his ship
and it's pretty friggin impressive when
naomi asks about it he says it's one of
many and i'm interested to see what he
does
actually have here because it would be
difficult for anyone from the belt to be
able to go up against this
and taking fred johnson out makes it
less likely that anyone is going to be
able to organize a resistance
naomi is currently his prisoner we saw
her locked in her room at the end of
episode four
she initially came there to try to save
her son she's likely starting to
understand that he's a little too far
gone
he's sort of in the brainwashed category
at this point and so she's just gonna
have to figure
out how she can do something to
undermine them where she's at or she's
gonna have to try to escape
and man there's so much more that we
could talk about but i think that's a
good place to leave things off let's do
the rest in the comments
let me know what you're thinking if you
want to talk book spoilers that's cool
but make sure you mark them so other
people don't get spoiled
i think i'll be doing a full book
discussion video after episode 5 and
after episode 10
because there's a lot of stuff i've had
to leave out of these videos and it's
kind of killing me
so let me know what you think let me
know what you want to see please like
this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon